a kidnap princess a killer King and an
episode full of drug fuelled Joker's
let's discuss all the chaos together on
Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
welcome back river babes I hope you
enjoyed our mini hiatus because now
we're focusing on the final five
episodes of Riverdale season 3 yes of
course
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 318 chapter 53 jawbreaker which
was jam-packed with outrageous moments
that kind of sort of made sense remember
I tried now today I'll be sharing my
hisses and kisses which are particularly
heavy on the kisses this time and
dropping some exclusive secrets straight
from Edgar ever never himself Chad
Michael Murray but first let's do a
super quick recap of all the biggest
moments in the blue-and-gold
breakdown as jug had an FP teamed up for
a little father-and-son investigating we
discovered that things had gotten even
crazier in Riverdale I find that hard to
believe
first jingle jangle then fizzle Roxanne
now apparently there's a new kind of
drug called G that makes people foam at
the mouth like rabid dogs and try and
kill themselves like they're in bird box
or something I was going on
juggen FP realized that Kurt was dealing
an altered batch of fizzle rocks but it
was all just a big distraction so that
that little brat Ricky could lure
princess jellybeans into The Gargoyle
Kings clutches he wanted to meet you who
did
meanwhile the only thing I'm gonna say
about Archie's arc is that he won
another boxing match yay but this time
he defeated one of the zombies from the
walking dead but the biggest storyline
of the week was Betty trying to get more
answers about the farms brainwashing
ways she tried to find out more from
Edgar ever and ever but he just told her
some bizarre story about how once he
went into the middle of the desert to
die but then he found a farm in an
undying love of this because sure okay I
don't know it's a nice story
Betty reached a new level of intensity
as she created a fake grave for Charles
and then freaking chloroformed her mom
and then handcuffed her to a bed I just
hope she washed the sheets she tried to
reverse brainwash Alice back into her
old breakfast loving self but in the end
she realized that she had to release her
mom back into the wild and by that I
mean
Evelyn's arms take care of her please
now with Alice gone it looks like newly
divorced Hal is hoping to creep back
into the picture I just want to come out
didn't you murder people yeah I'm not
sure how you're gonna get out pretty
sure you're supposed to stay in jail but
cool we'd be insane if we let you out
yeah you are never getting out of here
but we need to talk about the fact that
Betty casually dropped a massive romance
revelation on us this week are you
engaged to occur so what's really going
on with these potential farmy fiance's
yeah well take a look at what Chad
Michael Murray had to tell me when I
grilled him about Edgar and Alice the
word engagement came up in this week's
episode what's going on is Edgar engaged
to Alice hey mixed feelings about this
Edgar and I have a deep understanding of
one another he's uh yeah yeah yep yep
I'm trying to figure out how not to give
too much away but let's just say yeah I
mean I think Alice is somebody that was
incredibly enticing to him and she's a
strong member in the community she also
has strong ties to everybody in
Riverdale so if you're going to find a
wife there is no better suitor
do I hear farm wedding bells ringing oh
yeah come on Andy
like it's the literal sense a white
wedding I'm curious to know what has the
reaction been like for you from the fans
who love Alice and FP together have they
reached out via social media well
fortunately I am NOT a big comment
reader but when I do they seem to be all
very loving and very positive so thank
you so very much for not attacking me or
Edgar for that matter Alice needs to be
happy you can't judge I'd get for that
she is making tremendous progress
towards finding her truest self so what
are we calling them Ripper babes e galas
Algar I don't know tell me your thoughts
in the comments below and how you're
really feeling about this new Riverdale
romance but now let's fully focus on all
the love in seven seconds
in heaven kicking things off we had
quite a bit of virtue flirting this week
as Veronica is all of the sudden
involved in Archie's gym for some reason
thank you for believing I'm always in
your corner thank goodness they threw
Josie into the episode for a scene
because honestly I almost totally forgot
that our chose E was still a thing as
for Shoni well this was quite an
emotional rollercoaster ride for these
two ladies Toni was baffled to see that
her BAE was all of a sudden ditching her
signature colour so she could spend all
her time walking in slow motion with the
rest of the farm EES
how the hell did my girlfriend become
queen of far me so versa Edgar with
Betty's help Tony tried to remind Cheryl
that her brother Jason is also dead she
even had the tape to prove it plus she
even tried to seduce her lady love into
leaving the farm I need you tonight
in every way mind body soul mostly body
but by the end of the episode Cheryl
tearfully confessed that the farm was
giving her an ultimatum Evelyn said I
have to make a choice Jason are you and
just like that
Toni ditched her leather jacket if the
pretty poisons is still even a thing and
joined her girlfriend as one of the
white walkers of Riverdale luckily it
looks like Betty may have finally found
the perfect spy there we go
great no one suspects anything and with
that wonderful twist let's switch into
hisses and kisses hisses to some of the
weird revelations they tried to feed us
this week thanks to the return of the
ultra creepy coroner he told jug that
baby teeth died from loss
blood from having his teeth ripped out
while he was still alive I thought I'd
seen the true face of evil but this
isn't even human but thanks to a quick
google search and the fact that I talked
to my mom who's a dentist I'm gonna say
this is false this is bonkers I have no
idea what's going on but I don't really
care have a blessed day
his sister yet another boring boxing
match
stop trying to entice us with Archie's
ABS because I'm so sick of seeing all
the fake blood and the high-stakes
matches that I couldn't care less about
hisses - putting jellybeans in harm's
way and hisses - the fact that Kevin
Keller's only role in this episode was
to walk in the back I might add of those
farmy fashion shows give Kevin the time
to shine why can't he have his own
storyline for once that's all we've ever
wanted to do switching over to kisses
that one is still going to Kevin for
looking so damn good with the teeny tiny
amount of screen time they've given him
kisses to Tony for putting Evelyn in her
place with this iconic moment I'm not
gonna let you ruin her ruin her [ __ ] I
love her and she loves me and kisses to
Betty and Tony's newfound friendship
this week kisses to Betty's off the
walls behavior sorry not sorry but you
can keep your wig because I'm loving
this dark Betty I'm loving her fierce
love for her mom and I was especially
tickled by her not so subtle threat to
Evelyn
you and if you don't believe me ask
around people will tell you what I'm
capable of
kisses to Alice we're doing an amazing
job as Riverdale's newest on-camera
reporter you're doing great sweetie live
from the south side I'm Alice Smith our
ivw and lastly kisses - Fred's brief but
amazing moment offering his son some
words of wisdom a little close to the
the Sun there is yeah and now we're done
thank you so much for tuning in this
week and be sure to check back with me
next time for our Sweetwater secrets
preview for episode 319 chapter 54 fear
the reaper where i'll be chatting with
you live but first you know what to do
give this video a like hit subscribe and
then head on down to the comments to
tell me your kisses and kisses for 3/18
what do you think about Alice and
Edgar's potential engagement are you
worried for Shoni and who else is tired
of the boxing storyline tell me
everything River babes and I'll see you
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]